non mais je me rappelle cyril qu'on se
connaissait pas tu m'avais envoyé un
message pendant la grande grève de radio
france / 2015 en dix ans qu'on se
connaît pas mais ce que vous faites
parce qu'on se rend à l'époque c'est
super tenez vos existences j'ai tenu bon
et finalement les résultats ils sont là
puisque le groupe de radio s'est jamais
aussi bien portée mais c'est vrai que de
l'intérieur ça et ça tangue et depuis ça
ça roule bien il est mis sur les rails
et moi c'est vrai que j'aime pas qu'on
voit là quand il ya un espèce de
lynchage l'acharnement resta
d'acharnement sur mathieu qui avait fait
un travail exceptionnel à radio france
or les résultats taille encore un
puisque radio france et cartonne on le
voit on la radio france à tous les tous
les tous les deux mois lorsque lé
résultat radio c'est important pour vous
de parler après avoir été lavé des
accusations qui a été fait à votre
rencontre oui c'était important parce
que je voulais apporter un témoignage à
plusieurs tiroirs un témoignage sur ce
monde politico médiatique c'est celui
qui va intéresser gens dire le grand
public parce que on voit que ces féroces
un témoignage aussi sur mon parcours qui
je suis parce que les gens avaient
l'image quelqu un mec assez froid le
beau gosse enfin gillain ces trucs là
c'est pas malin d'avoir l'image de bonal
non ouais non je dis quand on a une
image de beau gosse les gens se disent
en fait il a rien dans le citron est en
fait même un problème
exemple et est donc en fait c'est
vraiment le sujet je voulais raconter
qui j'étais d'où je viens moi je suis
d'une famille de classe moyenne élevée
dans un milieu rural dans le sud-ouest
de la france et j'ai ce parcours qui m'a
permis d'avoir la carrière qu'on connaît
et puis je voulais apporter aussi un
témoignage sur le travail de
transformation radio france parce
qu'effectivement la boîte elle a
sacrément bouger donc c'est vrai que je
virais beaucoup de gens en arrivant on a
changé 70% de la grille de france inter
donc forcément il y en a quelques-uns
qui n'est pas content et forcément une
vengeance ils vont trouver des relais
après politique à droite à gauche et
puis après finalement ça se coalisent un
peu et ça rendait en vacances et ccc
c'est vrai que c'est une succession de
choses alors vous invite à la tête de
radio france de 2014 à 2018 vous
décrivez cette période comme ayant été
écrite pour un scénario de série vous
raconter des coups tordus les trahisons
dont dans je vous cite le monde
impitoyable des médias et de la
politique
et vous revenez notamment on va revenir
sur la rumeur d'une liaison avec
emmanuel macron rumeur une rumeur que le
président avait choisi de rendre public
lors d'un meeting à bobigny en 2017
livres ont ainsi votre nom à toute la
presse voilà on a les images on se
rappelle de sa station sans vous
prévenir c'était fou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voiture comme emma pages tout de ma vie
forme matin elle se demande simplement
fini
sa vie dans les dîners en ville sinon
les bouches de métro faut 10
gw avait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai que ça c'était
incroyable vous a quand vous avez appris
que emmanuel macron que vous avez cités
sc une deux scènes que j'ai retranscrit
dans livre je suis en train de dîner
chez une amie ce soir là avec quelques
personnalités qui sont connues notamment
jean claude gaudin qui était le maire de
marseille et puis je vois mon portable
qui vivre là dans ma poche et je vois
des copains journalistes limite était au
courant par sms je veux dire courant de
cours a donc là je vais sur twitter et
je vois effectivement que le candidat
emmanuel macron vient de sortir le coup
d'hologrammes donc bon je suis un peu
quand même perturbé parce que bien sûr
que la rumeur elle courait depuis des
semaines j'en veux dire même des mois je
raconte dans le bouquin ma propre grand
mère qui à 80 ans à l'époque reçoit des
mails on lui dit il ya une photo qui va
sortir du maquereau avec galets main
dans la main dans un bois il
m'apprend grand-mère qui m'appelle chi
minh tu sais mon chéri j'ai reçu ça mais
oui tu connais ma vie ma miss et c'est
pas très crédible quoi et donc voilà
donc il on le savait il a pris la
décision et je pense que c'était la
bonne décision de bien sûr et de le
prendre avec eux aussi attendant le coup
la référence aux à mélenchon avec
l'hologramme et où c'est vrai que
j'aurais préféré qu'ils m'appellent
alors il faut vous avez un lendemain
vous appelez lendemain il vous a dit
allô matthieussent emmanuel macron je
vais vous dire que j'ai parlé de nous
hier soir ce n'était pas un mais que la
seule prononciation par l'un de ces deux
protagonistes suffisait à faire exister
ce nous c'était emmanuel et mathieu se
noue c'était une fiction elle semblait
tellement crédible que le futur
président de la république avait décidé
de la rendre possible par la parole ce
que vous dites dans livres ouais c'est
en fait le téléphone sonne c'est un
numéro masqué mots j'aime pas trop les
numéros masqués en général et puis là je
sais pas pourquoi on m a dit que c'était
lui et j'avais pas envie de parler ouais
en fait j'étais un peu en colère oui
c'est un riche homme en colère et puis
voilà il m'a laissé un message plutôt
sympa rigaux art parce qu'on fait l'un
et l'autre
ce truc de dingue mais connaissiez pas
du tout non enfin on se connaît parce
que moi j'ai été président de l'ina
l'une des secrétaires générales jour
elle disait c'est une relation
professionnelle mais on n'est pas un
timon né voilà et est donc cep cette
rumeur c'est une création de toutes
pièces c'est pas juste d'un pote et on a
attiré le fil en disant c'est plus qu'un
pote non c'est une relation
professionnelle donc il ya bien
quelqu'un qui a créé ce sale bruit pas
pour me nuire à moi c'était pour lui
n'ira lui parce que la cible clairement
se dire un candidat dont on dit qu'il a
une double vie parce qu'en fait on ne
croit pas à son histoire perso j'y vois
là on crée une cochonnerie comme ça et
moi en fait j'étais le candidat pour
pour 7 pour cette rumeur donc en fait on
a jamais reparlé après après vous ont
choisi vous c'est ça pour moi ça n'est
pas parce qu'on est les la même année
avec emmanuel macron on a assez vite
réussi chacun dans son domaine - les
médias lui la politique voilà moi je le
dis dans le bouquin il ya il ya deux
points qui nous rapproche peut-être
c'est le rôle de nos grands mères on
sait sa grand mère maternelle a beaucoup
compté dans son éducation intellectuelle
et ma grand mère aussi geneviève à qui
je passe le bonjour ce soir parce qu
elle l à 89 ans maintenant a aussi
beaucoup compté dans ma vie je raconte
dans le livre voilà ça c'est voilà c'est
de parallélisme parle il ya un instant
de cette rumeur qui a été vraiment tout
c'est que c'était une rumeur d'habitude
une rumeur c'est vrai que ça s'arrête un
peu aux gens du métier là tout est aux
commandes c'est remercie pour ça que je
pense qu emmanuel macron on a parlé
cette rumeur de liaison entre vous
emmanuel macron je pense que c'est moi
je pense que l'avoir fait comme ça avec
humour je pense que ça
a brisé la glace et je pense que ça je
pense que c'était la bonne la bonne
solution c'est la meilleure exactement
il ya que lui qui pouvait en parler
c'était lui qui était quand même
concerné moi j'étais juste un objet au
milieu mais en fait il a traité avec
humour par contre on a vu que ça fait
exploser le nombre de requêtes au tour
de radio france puisqu'il se trouve que
quinze jours après ce ce meeting où il
en parle je suis avec mon équipe de
radio france en californie on va visiter
les grandes entreprises californiennes
on arrive chez google et là il ya
welcome radio france et puis une vie va
regarder le nombre de fois où on cherche
radio france sur google ait à google sur
un écran géant on est tout d'un coup
l'augmentation 500% de roquettes on voit
radio france mathieu gallet manuel macro
donc ça avait quand même partout dans le
monde c'est et puis il ya eu beaucoup de
médias russes ont remédié entre
guillemets qui ont alimenté le truc qui
a conduit des manips des vrais
manipulations autour de cette rumeur
pour perturber la campagne de 2007 le
livret est passionnant et vous parlez
beaucoup de cette rumeur et notamment du
rôle potentiel de brigitte macron et
vous écrivez à un moment autour d'elle
c'est une citation autour d'elle certes
un petit marquis sont venus remuer le
couteau dans la plaie donc ma question
elle est simple est-ce que vous pensez
que brigitte macron et l'elysée ont joué
un rôle actif dans votre éviction qui
vous ont poussé à la démission de radio
france ce qui en fait c'est passé sur
radio france soyons clair c'est que en
fait cyril hanouna a raconté j'ai été
effectivement condamné en première
instance pour des contrats de
consultants qui n'auraient pas respecté
et code des marchés publics quand
j'étais président derrière effectivement
le csa qui est le seul à nommer et
pouvoir révoquer les présidents des
médias publics a fait une enquête est
effectivement a souhaité que je parte je
pouvais le comprendre même si c'était
très dur à vivre personnellement c'était
très dur pour les équipes parce qu'on
l'a dit un super boulot qui a été fait
voilà moi je suis parti je me suis
révolté une vie après ce qui est sûr
c'est que vous savez il ya toujours dans
les histoires comme ça des rumeurs et
gens qui veulent faire leur important
qui viennent mettre un petit peu de poil
à gratter et tout ça donc le népal les
principaux protagonistes
ils sont au dessus de ça il ya toujours
des gens qui essaient effectivement de
faire les malins et je pense qu'il ya
des gens effectivement on voit tout le
monde même pas géré quand vous faites de
son bouger les choses quand vous voilà
vous êtes comme moi avec un esprit assez
entreprenant je suis pas quelqu'un qui
se laisse faire plutôt castagneur jamais
forcément vous fait pas que des amis
donc il ya des gens qui aient envie de
vous dézinguer alors c'est vrai je vous
le confirme
raconte également avoir été victime
d'autres rumeurs en cours de votre
carrière certaines personnes ont insinué
que vous aviez été nommé président de la
radio de radio france en 2014 uniquement
parce que vous étiez homosexuel et que
le président du csa olivier schrameck
président de l'époque serait tombé sous
votre charme alors que l'homosexualité
présumée du président du csa est
également une rumeur faussement fonder
d'autres aussi raconté que votre statut
de protégé de frédéric mitterrand vous a
permis d'accéder à ces postes de pouvoir
énormément drôle ya beaucoup
d'homophobie en fait la tente dans tous
âges et on imagine des histoires gérard
jour des histoires de fesses voilà non
mais c'est servir de vie il est là c'est
pas pour les bonnes raisons voilà bah en
fait bah comme il ya de la misogynie
quoi il ne fallait qu'ils réussissent
toujours des questions au fait pourquoi
est ce qu'elle a réussi c'est pas parce
qu'elle est juste la meilleure c'est
qu'on dirait ce qu'il n'y a pas un truc
derrière tout ça alors en plus si vous
avez la malchance hier d'être
effectivement jeunes en bonne santé avec
une bonne tête il ya les gens se disent
non c'est pas votre talent ce n'est pas
le travail que vous avez fait bouger
mois pour arriver où j'en suis j'ai
bossé j'ai fait des études enfin j'ai
dit j'ai eu dans ma famille sur des
premiers qui a fait des études
supérieures vient de voir arriver là par
l'opération du saint-esprit où par je ne
sais quelle protection et donc faut tout
le temps se battre et en fait c'est ce
que j'ai envie d'y aussi dans ce bouquin
c'est quand vous êtes différent quand
votre parcours est pas exactement celui
des grands patrons traditionnel faut se
battre faut croire en soi faut pas
lâcher faut avoir confiance en soi
tracer sa route j'irai à la fin on gagne
alors vous évoquez également vous réglez
vos comptes notamment avec fleur
pellerin ex calicots ministre de la
culture prêcheur d'un four permet
justement confond avec away exactement
catimini de la culture à l'époque vous
raconter comment cette mini de la
culture de françois hollande aurait
voulu obtenir votre prédiction que chez
radio france et vous dites qu'elle a été
soutenu par manuel valls qui était un
premier ministre à l'époque oui alors
les rapports avec fleur pellerin ils
sont très très dur parce que pendant la
grande grève en 2015 qui dure un mois à
radio france il ya bien quelqu'un qui
doit porter le chapeau de cette grotte
de cette grève dont on n'arrive pas à
sortir donc c'est soit le dirigeant sur
moi soit la ministre qui a pas vu les
problèmes arrivent et ou qui a pas su
les résoudre et à la fin c'est une lutte
vraiment sans merci tous les coups sont
permis on va aller m'en ressortir mais
justement des contrats du temps l'ina et
toutes les semaines le canard enchaîné
pendant six semaines qui sort des trucs
en permanence dos est vraiment en
rafales et à la fin moi je tiens le bon
parce que le csa ne me lâche pas il
m'avait élu un en avant à l'unanimité
donc il n'avait pas se déjuger vous
donnant les audiences commençait déjà à
remonter moi je suis un coup j'avoue que
heureusement que j'avais
vie privée ma famille mes amis pour
tenir c'était quand même très violent
très dur vient de se prendre un
actionnaire donc l'état le canard
enchaîné l'inspection générale
et toutes vos dépenses pour montrer que
finalement l'histoire du bureau parce
qu'on m'a collé ça sature le dire avec
la novation dollar aurait coûté plus de
100 millions voilà ça c'est des choses
qui avait été décidée avant j'arrive à
radio france mais il a fallu une enquête
de l'inspection des finances pour me
blanchir à ce jour les syndicats oui
voilà c'est que l'essonne qui est devant
vous et des années après que certains
syndicats dont je tais le nom en trois
lettres avaient poussé à aurait poussé
le truc j'ai donc vraiment il y avait
des fronts de partouche plaisir faut
être assez solide est vraiment avoir
confiance en soi et être un bagarreur ce
que je suis pour pour tenir bon et à la
fin j'ai tenu et les résultats sont là
aujourd'hui vous êtes à la tête de
magellan président fondateur de magellan
dans cette plateforme vous avez envie
aussi de vous pouvez continuer et de
revenir aussi sur une sur une chaîne ou
sur un os et aujourd'hui j'ai créé avec
mon co fondateur atur verticaux cette
plateforme est ce studio de podcasts ça
va faire trois ans là dans dix jours
aujourd'hui on a 400 programmes on se
rend très bon programme je vous
recommande avec christophe rocancourt
par christophe rocancourt un sort jeudi
voilà on fait tout un une série sur des
personnalités un peu sulfureuse comme ça
je me suis inventé une vie dans le privé
entrepreneurs en une vingtaine ya
beaucoup de jeunes c'est une autre
ambiance moi ça m'a 40 balais ça m'a
permis d'avoir une vie après je dit pas
jamais que je reviendrai peut-être un
jour dans un grand groupe mais
aujourd'hui je suis à fond dans cette
entreprise et ça me va me va bien